reject nation in honor of thor love and
thunder the newest installment in the
mcu we are going to rank the entire mcu
now this is favorites this is my
experience not best because art is
objective so we're going to go through
this journey but we are going to include
the television shows i asked greg he
said no no film and i was like greg it's
important he's like okay that doesn't
make sense because the events of falcon
and the winter soldier are affecting
captain america four because now it's
captain america the winter soldier just
like in the comic books the events of
spider-man affect daredevil affect the
annuals affect the big events like
secret wars so too to the shows build up
to the movies it's all one shared
universe so we're gonna rank everything
all 36 properties we're gonna be going
through the whole thing and if you enjoy
this please do leave a comment let me
know what yours are as well and as
always like subscribe hit that
notification bell do all the things on
youtube that i always forget to say and
greg's like yeah that's the thing follow
me on tick tock i'm gonna do a lot of
these i'm gonna do a lot of rankings i
give you lots of comic book news movie
news all sorts of things over my tick
tock 15 one minute three minutes all
sorts of links i love tik tok i love you
guys more let's get into it
[Music]
at number 36 surprising absolutely no
one and if you know me you know i defend
this movie i'm not saying the movie's
bad but something had to end up at the
bottom thor the dark world now i think
this is a movie that really struggles
with tone changes and experiencing one
linear story i think a big problem with
this film is that loki was so good in
avengers they added that whole plot
which cost us a lot of interesting
details with malik i think malikith has
a lot of potential as a dark health to
be a very interesting villain but when
you combine that with trying to build
out the asgardian myth building out alan
taylor's version of this medieval world
we built into i think it did cost us a
lot of very interesting storyline that
combined with the natalie portman jane
foster having various degrees of
chemistry plus balancing a lot of comedy
with kat dennings and the comedy of thor
while thor's evolving from his fish out
of water into this warrior which then
changes entirely i think it's a very
difficult film in the entirety of the
mcu this film does however benefit from
some later on changes retroactively
making a lot of the family elements so
important it's an important film but
something had to end up last in my
opinion for the dark world number 35 and
i am so sorry i wanted to love this a
lot more than i actually did this movie
made a billion dollars so i am probably
in the minority here it is captain
marvel this movie to me was one of the
experiences where i was a little worried
about the shape of the mcu it did a lot
of things where it felt like it didn't
necessarily trust the audience there
were a lot of moments where there's her
rising up through montages over and over
again and i was like yes i love this
empowerment story i love what we're
going for but that's not you don't have
to tell me again i understand and i feel
like it didn't trust the audience it
also felt like two different versions of
a story i love these directors
mississippi grind is incredible and it's
kind of a funny story is one of my
favorite dramedies it didn't land for
the mcu it's also one of the first times
the film looked cheap it looked like it
telegraphed the twist that didn't feel
like a twist and we were supposed to
feel like it was a twist it does however
have one of my all-time favorite stan
lee cameos it also features some very
beautiful dragon ball zs action and i
really like brie larson as captain
marvel i want captain marvel 2 to be all
the things i wanted captain marvel 1 to
be and i think now that we've met her
we'll have that opportunity highest
hopes for nia costa to take over to be
honest all right coming in at 34 and
hopefully showing it's not a recency
bias this is a phase 4 experience which
means it's more recent and yet it didn't
land for me i try to look at the mcu as
a whole this is serialized almost
television there are so many
installments it does affect the whole
and we'll talk about that more as we get
into the middle of this whole run but
what if for me landed about 34 i think
it was trying to do two things it was
trying to build out the universe with
these really high stakes but
unfortunately the flaw of it was i never
felt like there were stakes it was
trying to grow things out cosmically it
was trying to expand the universe but it
never felt like anything that could
happen in what if could affect where we
went with the mcu and i think we really
saw that after with doctor strange
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness teased zombie strange wasn't the
same one it teased a undead wanda but
that was oil from ultron on her face it
teased a lot of the things we thought
were visual cues from what if but it
kind of undermined what if by not using
those characters there were moments that
absolutely sang i loved the animation
especially in the captain carter episode
i loved iron man cap i really really
enjoyed the story line with t'challa's
star-lord and all of those possibilities
but unlike the what if comics i never
felt like those events would matter and
i feel like in the mcu everything needs
to at least matter what if didn't quite
land for me never felt connected week to
week didn't feel like an event series
like the others did coming in at number
33 and now we're into the comfortable
bees i feel like these are all bees and
up unfortunately something had to be at
the bottom of the bees and that is iron
man 2. a lot of the things people don't
like about this movie i actually enjoy
it is a bit chaotic it is a lot of high
energy it does feel spontaneous but i
think a lot of that spontaneity though
it costs the film being 32 or higher is
fun to revisit i do think after armor
wars this film would be more important
just like end game and infinity war made
thor dark world better by retroactively
adding importance i feel like iron man 2
will do the same at the end of the day
it is still tony stark having a good old
time but it is john favreau hanging out
having a good time with iron man it has
maybe my favorite iron man suit up of
the entire cinematic universe that
suitcase suit is very cool visuals but
the lack of weight the lack of overall
importance and the overall rush this
came out two years after iron man 1
makes this about 33 and makes this the
lowest b ranking of the entire mcu for
me all right number 32 another b minus
for me is the first thor this movie i do
think is better than a lot of people
give it credit for it is a very fun
build out of both shakespearean and
comedy but it does suffer from having to
be a lot of things at once after iron
man and captain america we'd had more
traditional comic films iron man is
groundbreaking in a lot of ways but we'd
seen that type of movie before tony
stark and batman are pretty similar kind
of guys captain america is a war film
kind of like the rocketeer these are
familiar elements we're adding a thing
that is different from those elements in
this god world we're adding a literal
god of thunder that is a hard thing to
build out of so i give this movie a lot
of wiggle because it does balance the
gods it does balance the visuals of what
kenneth branagh was building with the
shakespearean lore and it does add a lot
of comedy think about the scene where he
wants to buy a horse big enough he can
ride or a bird or what have you think
about the another think about all those
things and then think about what they do
build out from and i think it's a lot
stronger than people remember but 31
other things are better number 31 and
still a b minus is incredible hulk the
incredible hulk i do think is slightly
better than these other ones for me
including thor i think we were gonna
have a really interesting edward norton
hulk but i do think the studio and
edward norton saw the hulk differently
if you hear and i'm not comparing this
movie two things that didn't get made
but if you hear any stories about what
hulk was gonna become in incredible hulk
2 with edward norton wanting to do this
kind of spiritual walk about this
existential movie pondering i think
that's where they wanted to go but
that's not exactly a team movie i think
mark ruffalo's hulk is an incredible
team hulk i love mark ruffalo's hulk
edward norton if you're gonna do the
solo endeavors if you're gonna have it
feel like the 70s comics if you're gonna
have it feel like the show i think this
is an incredible spiritual sequel to the
hulk show and i think edward norton is
an incredible hulk and i also think it's
a really fun time with the villain i
also think the world building is so
important that they brought back
thunderbolt ross and certain characters
one of the strengths of what if was
building out this world i just think
this world didn't fold in as neatly as
it needed to for the greater mcu and it
gets cost kind of getting eliminated in
the process and number 30 another recent
addition another show for me hawkeye
hawkeye did a lot of right things by
having the aha run and fractions
reflected on screen it did a lot of
great things by bringing us kate bishop
it had an incredible bridge sequence but
it did suffer in a lot of the ways that
what if did for me where it kind of
built up a lot of stakes and then
undermined them i do enjoy some of the
twists and turns marvel does with
playing with characters i don't
necessarily love how kingpin landed
after all that setup kingpin we saw in
the same actor in the same portrayal in
the same universe now technically with
daredevil as that dark r-rated crush a
guy's head in the car door it's very
hard when we're immediately trained from
a major character that's been built up
the whole season maybe if he wasn't
built up for six episodes it would have
felt differently but since we had all
that build up it did undermine things
this is as high as it is because the
chemistry with kate bishop and jeremy
renner's hawkeye is incredible i did
enjoy a lot of the action and
choreography with ronin i did think
having the bros as much as we did was
the right move imagine if the ending was
hammerheaded he was the cartoonish
version we got of kingpin how much
better the show would have landed and
that put it at this 30 spot and my
number 29 is the first ant-man i am one
of the folks that do enjoy ant-man and
the wasp a little bit more than ant-man
the first ant-man gave us a captivating
scott lang and introduced us to a very
fun michael douglas tank on hank pym but
it did suffer for me from a phase one
villain problem and it was a little too
deep in the mcu to let that just go i
love cory stole the actor i never really
felt all too threatened by yellowjacket
and i did feel like it was doing the
thing they did in phase one where it's
like what if the villain chose this turn
instead but not landing it a lot of the
fun of these villains is that they're
mirrors of their character a lot of the
fun of these characters is that you
understand where both the villain and
the hero are coming from i do
unfortunately felt like the limited
screen time the overall plot of the
technology and all of those things they
were building to and the corporate
espionage led corey stoll to give us in
the editing room maybe not even on the
day a little bit too mustache twirling
and the mustache twirling made this film
feel like it was just an okay side
mission and ant-man's a hard enough
character to land so the paul rudd charm
and all those things make it where it
does but the villain puts this in the
lower range of the beast and the next
one up 28 ant-man and the wasp to me
this is improvement over the first
because the villains work a lot better
for me we have even less screen time
with ghosts but i was invested in ghost
i cared about her journey i was very
invested in lawrence fishburne as
goliath i was super interested in the
dynamic between ant-man and the wasp
more this time because in the first film
i felt like they kept saying like i'm
the one that trained for this i could do
great at this and then they're like but
we're not gonna let her like there was
like three sets of jokes about the wasp
being more prepared and not doing it and
then in this movie they're like oh we
should probably let the wasp be the wasp
so that's already an improvement over
the first one for me i thought the fight
choreography is so great in this i
thought the use of the fun visual
aesthetic a la honey i shrunk the kid
with the giant hello kitty exploding the
use of the car david the small tune got
more to do and more to play with here
the supporting cast felt like they had
already formed the team that's so
important in that fun run in the comics
the team felt like they were as
important as ant-man and to me when
you've got an ensemble cast like this
that's essential so you add an ensemble
cast the charm of paul rudd the
greatness of the wasp and villains that
actually work i do think ant-man the
wasp is a solid b and above his
predecessor another solid b and my 27th
pick this one's interesting this one's
very recent is doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and i think this
movie is largely subjective of your
experience of the style of filmmaking on
one hand it's been really tricky phase
one through three where you've had to
live in between these walls of the
sandbox following in the mcu and making
sure your artistic style kind of ebbed
and flowed but if you look at what james
gunn did with guardian he was able to
make it his while also working in the
cosmic parameters of marvel i do think
this is very much an incredible sam
raimi film it is a solid b for me
because sam raimi got to flex his
creative muscles that he uses so well
and he got to tell an incredibly
captivating story unfortunately that
incredibly captivating visually
very apparently lush story that
stylistically sang sacrificed for me
scarlet witch who had been on a journey
with for so many so many years we'd seen
one through six of her ten moment arc
and then it felt like we went to nine
and ten i needed to see seven and eight
i got to enjoy one through six and then
nine and ten but she literally did a
heel turn visually into a color palette
and it felt like it sacrificed too much
for this to be higher while enjoying the
film i think that didn't work within the
mcu if this was a what if and they made
the what if an anthology series it might
be in my top 15 mark number 26 and
probably a lot lower than other people
putting this on their list maybe one of
my most controversial age of ultron
avengers age of ultron is a lot like
dark world in that it retroactively has
solved a lot of problems but it's like
five movies at once and unlike avengers
one and infinity war end game it feels
like it it suffers a bit from a mix of
tonalities there are so many moments
that were vision wielding mjolnir them
all talking in the barn the scene with
thor and hawkeye's family is one of my
favorite all-time mcu scenes but
unfortunately a lot of those moments
feel like a series scattering of things
and ultron didn't really feel like he
had an age it was like the moment of
ultron and i understand why they had to
do that and i understand what the ultron
character was trying to represent and i
love the concept of ai and these
overwhelming odds and what it means to
be self-aware and i love the headier
concepts but because it was already
juggling so many things and because it
killed the fastest man alive i get he
was sacrificing if rocket was a great
moment it didn't feel like the
characters all got their time to shine
in the right way it all felt like they
were trying to share it felt like they
were all in a play and everyone wanted
the last line and no one could have the
last line and that went on for far too
long to make this any higher for me
number 25 another very strong solid b
for me is doctor strange one i rewatched
this recently and it actually went up a
few numbers in my ranking because i
realized the visuals and the world
building and everything that we had to
accomplish with the mythology is so
dense and so much and also really
looking at it compared to what i think
they've been doing with phase four i was
really impressed that it was so
different unfortunately and this is no
one that actually worked on the film's
fault tony stark and dr steven strange
have very similar origins and a lot of
times i found myself even on re-watches
wanting to watch iron man especially
because the villain in this casilius
never felt like it was doing a lot for
me in the film i dug the ancient one i
dug wong i dove the entire world of
doctor strange but without the villain
really working i kept wanting to go back
to the the cloak of levitation i just
felt more drawn to than this and i love
the inceptionist visuals and i love that
the mythology felt real i feel like i
could pick up a book from within this
world and learn about it because scott
derrickson built such a lush world but i
also feel like because the villain
wasn't higher i couldn't rank this
higher than 25 as much as i loved or
mamu i think if you took out cassellius
just had the dormammo story and his
training it'd be in my top 15. number 24
and one of the first marvel films to
make me cry guardians of the galaxy 2.
this film is just chock full of daddy
issues and they all really landed
because you were already so emotionally
invested in these characters that's how
you do a sequel you build up the
emotional investment in the first and
then you tell an insane larger than
larger than life story in the second i
never thought we'd see ego the living
planet in the mcu now that seems almost
normal after the events of dark world
and all the things we've had but this
time five years ago 2017 that is just
such an abstract concept and as played
by kurt russell there are so many scenes
that are the most absurd thing spelling
them out and they work so well in this
film the reason this film is so high up
for me is because it grabs the absurd it
grabs the visuals of james gunn it adds
the irreverent humor of james gunn and
it puts it all in a box that feels like
it is both in the mcu like the most
guardians of the galaxy from the obscure
comics of the 70s thing i could ever
imagine it is the perfect amalgamation
of tones if you're into this world while
not being as good as the first one but
still building out the universe i think
this film really works in a lot of ways
i just don't find myself re-watching it
as often and that's why it's so low 23
here we are with black widow this is a
film that i think if it had come out in
phase two or phase three would also be
higher and i think me personally reading
comic books continuity's a real question
mark like i can accept watching a black
widow movie after she already died maybe
more than people that are just in the
film and tv versions of marvel like it
didn't bother me nearly that much what
did bother me is that i was so so in for
the jason bourne tone i was so in
florence pew getting her time to shine
and and do that soft reboot so we get
her as a black widow i was so in for
david harbor i was so in for the action
set pieces but i didn't love that we got
all of the brutality in some scenes and
didn't get the brutality of taskmaster
and others i love the idea of taskmaster
being from her past like she was i love
the idea of the taskmaster twist i i
think her being a female villain is
interesting because she wouldn't have to
be you know physically a certain way
especially in that kind of suit but
making it robotic removing the power set
of taskmaster studying undermines a very
important character the greater mcu and
this villain kind of messed up the comic
continuity in a way that i couldn't
really let this movie be higher even
though my experience of watching the
movie and the other nine tenths of the
movie was something i really really
enjoyed this is a strong b plus for me
personally another b plus is captain
america the first avenger this one lands
right here because it builds out a very
interesting world this was so early in
the mcu and it's still so interesting
you get the red skull on screen as hugo
weaving which is so captivating but i do
feel there are some moments of i don't
feel the menace of the red skull and
that's one of the reasons i'm excited
for dr doom is i feel like where marvel
didn't know what to do with overarching
villains they did do great work with
bringing back an infinity war but i did
feel like the red skull of the comics is
so ominous and i felt some of that in
the movie but i loved the character
design i loved the
vehicle and weapon design i love the
entire world built this over extreme
rocketeer world and the relationship
with bucky and steve is incredible the
transformation of steve rogers from that
skinny steve to the steve we need to
this day holds up visually the things
they're able to do with visual effects
practical effects and cgi combined
together i know two of those redundant
but putting that all together into one
beautiful thing this movie holds up so
well and i think the strength of this
movie is a huge part that the mcu has
done as well as it have because we trust
and we need captain america another
solid b-plus and this one's interesting
because it's kind of a twist if you guys
have noticed i've really had faults with
the villains that have knocked the movie
down for me because i think a movie is
only as good as its villain a lot of
things can work but if the villain
doesn't that personally affects my
experience of the film this one is
interesting because to me spider-man is
about new york and spider-man hasn't
been in new york much especially in far
from home spider-man far from home we'd
been to space we'd touched on new york
but then we went to europe and a lot of
that didn't really work for me i really
wanted some small town spider-man we'll
get to the most recent spider-man
because of its improvements as we go
along but a lot of the comedy didn't
quite land with some of the
relationshipy stuff but overall it is a
very very pleasant experience some of
the best visuals i have ever seen for
spider-man hard stop and the best
villain i could imagine for a spider-man
sequel i think jake schillenhall's
mysterio is one of the few prophetic
villains in the mcu we're gonna see more
and more drone culture we're gonna see
more and more deep fakes we're gonna see
more and more that we won't yet
understand if it's real or not mysterio
played on a character written in the 60s
modernized it made it prophetic and
managed to incorporate it into the
greater mcu that is the best magic trick
you can pull in the mcu you make it a
seed you've already planted you make it
something that's going to be even more
relevant in the future you cast jake
gyllenhaal getting to do his most
theater kid performance like he i i it's
the combination of donnie darko jake
gyllenhaal day after tomorrow jake
gyllenhaal and nightcrawler jake
gyllenhaal one character and you put
that in a cgi spectacle with that
incredible remedia sequence i loved
mysterio on this i loved the visuals in
this some of the things didn't work but
it's still a very high b plus for me far
from home number 20 is falcon and the
winter soldier
i don't know why retroactively this has
become like not as beloved but week to
week this was such a journey this was
such event television and especially
there's a sequence and i believe it's
the fifth episode where u.s agent
literally decapitates someone with his
shield and i thought that was a
fascinating commentary on the world
today comic books i'm sorry for any
people in this chat that are going to
get mad at me for saying this are
political there's this guy captain
america he's punching nazis in the 40s
and still punching nazis today i thought
using a show about falcon becoming
captain america and addressing certain
brutality and addressing certain current
events was very
very brave and very important
storytelling add to that you get an
actual therapy session all of phase four
is about therapy all these characters
need therapy bucky goes to [ __ ]
therapy and it's required i love that
this invested in white uh white wolf i
love this invested in winter soldier
separately i love that this invested in
falcon and in captain america separately
this kind of has four leads and of
course their civilian identities i loved
all of the stuff in new orleans i love
that anthony mackie felt like he got to
bring his nest to sam wilson and i
especially loved baron zemo i never
thought i'd be as invested in the daniel
bruhl take on berensema after civil war
and now he's up there of my all-time
favorite villains and why i think
thunderbolts will work is because of
this show 19 and guaranteed to get me
into hot water with mcu fans is thor
ragnarok you heard me thor ragnarok i
know a lot of people love it and i
really enjoy it but to me it is a lot of
leaps in my uh approachability to the
character i think that ragnarok gave us
the best thor we've ever had in infinity
war and endgame because it balanced the
drama and the comedy but while it's just
comedy ragnarok is a lot for me i do
think there's a lot of things that feel
like they're done for the joke not for
the story i feel like at points it does
feel improv troopy which doesn't fit the
rest of the mcu for me doesn't
necessarily fit the comic book for me
but what it does do it give me
spectacular visuals give me world war
hulk build out the universe give me the
best possible jeff goldblum this movie
is so insane that jeff goldblum at an 11
doesn't feel out of place i love thor
screaming going through that tunnel i
love thor dealing with a very
cantankerous hulk i love all of these
things but it didn't feel like it was
the character i'd been living with or
the character that i know from the
comics again if this was a what if if
this was removed or if this came after i
don't know a different thor three that
gave us a little more comment it just it
felt like a lot to go from two to this
three a lot worked grand master the
villain hella is on my rushmore of
villains what it did for sadness what it
did to continue thor's walkabout journey
of figuring out who he is by removing
his very people he's the god of asgard
and they took away most of asgard who
are you as a man without your people if
you're a king it asks a lot of important
questions does a lot of fun things but
overall isn't as high as a lot of people
for me number 18 and right above
ragnarok for similar reasons and you've
heard me talk about this a lot recently
is thor love and thunder you know i have
some issues with some of the tonality i
do enjoy the second half the film quite
a bit i do have some problems with the
first half of the film but some of the
things i especially enjoyed were the
family aspects i really enjoyed the way
this movie lands i do think the last
five minutes are amongst my favorite
five minutes at the end of any mcu film
post credits were absolutely that phase
one post-credit glory but the movie
itself did feel like it was figuring
itself out as it went along i feel like
we got a very different movie that
landed in theaters than the four hour
assembly cut which we don't need to see
it's not the snyder cut the thing that
went into the edit i feel like might
have been a very different movie i could
have used some more butchering i could
have used some more jane foster i could
have used a lot more king valkyrie as it
stands now it's it's in the middle of my
marvel experience but what made it so
interesting was everything they did to
make me feel for gore i really loved
gore i really think tyke is two for two
with villains i really understood where
he was coming from i really empathized
with him and i really liked all the
choices they made visually around him
but some of the comedy didn't work for
me so it's about the middle for marvel
higher than people would expect number
17 is moon knight i know a lot of folks
uh didn't love how this landed and that
kind of colored their entire experience
of the film it did change my experience
this had been a little bit higher i
didn't necessarily love episode six but
i did adore episodes one through five i
love the psychology i love the talent of
oscar isaac on display every episode the
scene outside the steak restaurant is
some of the best acting in marvel and
i'm not letting that go because it
didn't have the exact end i wanted i
also think if they made the post credit
scene actually part of the show like
just tie it in that would have elevated
the whole experience it's weird little
details and choices the cgi on some of
the fights didn't quite work for me i
know there's budgetary constraints i
know it's a tv show but those little
things chipped away at it but everything
else worked for me i love that there's a
moon night show that feels like moon
night this feels like lemire smallwood
run come to life this feels like ellis
this feels like declan shalvie this
feels like the things i've always loved
about moon knight with the mythology
with the world building with the insane
fight club elements and oscar isaac and
ethan hawk acting their eyeballs out at
each other and introducing very obscure
characters i never thought we'd see on
screen this is very high for me because
it showed mythology as well as gods as
well as superheroes is absolutely
possible and we got [ __ ] moonlight
guy pierce is the guy from memento and i
really think up until he got that
mustache twirly firebreather stuff at
work i'm also one of the folks that
really liked the twist with the mandarin
i think it evolved even more using the
one shot i think that stuff really
worked i love the idea of iconography
being perverted into something wrong i
like the idea of us using these symbols
of heroes to make things not as
trustworthy i think all that sings
especially in the world of the comic
books i think iron man 3 we're going to
look back on in years as one of the most
important comic book films it is
certainly one of the best made and i
think one of the best acted and it's
absolutely an a-modest for me i love
iron man 3. number 15 is the tv show
that i would argue changed comic book
television wandavision wandavision
started as this beautiful commentary on
tv and comic books themselves it's both
a commentary and comic book characters
and television as a medium and it
evolved both i love the characterization
of where they took scarlet witch from
scarlet witch into wanda maximoff and
back i love her dedication to her
children i love that we told this
heartbreaking story of humanity through
a witch and a robot i love their love i
love the supporting cast i loved the
mystery every single week everyone was
talking for the entire six and a half
day span about what had just happened on
the show because we were wrapped up in
this mystery i love that had
philosophical concepts like the ship of
theseus brought to our attention if
everything changes in a person are they
still that person but by way of vision i
love that this was the kat dennings
character i always wanted to see it get
some more time to shine every character
in the show work every beat of action
and comedy no not every 90 beats of
action comedy work and it was so close
to perfect the end for me was a slight
foil because i had a fumble because i do
feel like it went to punching and
kicking when it had just been so
philosophical but we kind of needed to
see where it would escalate with these
characters this show is a solid a minus
for me and i think it's one of the best
experiences i've had week to week with
marvel fans not only do you invest in
the beginning in the practical martial
arts of chongqing that bus scene is some
of the best we've seen a fight being the
mcu but by the third act you're in an
entirely new world you're dealing with
creatures we've never seen before you're
dealing with the re-emergence of the guy
you thought was the mannered in a
beautiful new creative and funny way and
you're watching them fight a dragon and
it all still feels like it's in the mcu
and you want a shanxi 2 as much as you
want him to be in the avengers that's a
very important distinction for a lot of
phase 4 films i wasn't as invested in
the greater mcu or i wasn't as invested
in the solo story this walked both lines
and introduced us to a new hero and did
it perfectly love chongqi all right you
know how hotels sometimes don't have the
number 13 on their elevator we're not
going to technically have a number 13 in
this list because miss marvel's not over
yet as of filming this we haven't seen
episode six of miss marvel as of right
now miss marvel falls somewhere after
juan division after shanghai but if it
lands if it sticks the landing i think
that might put it around chongqi so i'm
not exactly sure where it lands but i as
of right now consider miss marvel the a
that i consider shongxi and wan division
so it's in this range it might be 13 it
might be 16 but it's in this span miss
marvel for me is doing something really
really difficult it's making an audience
that's lived in this world for 14 years
appreciate something that might just be
for 14 year olds or 40 year olds this
show appeals to a young audience as well
as the audience that's grown up with
this world this is the first show where
someone in the universe knows about the
universe there's an avenger con in this
world with the wrong set of hands
without the gloves they used on this
this could be a disaster
self-referential stuff is very hard to
walk she's literally a fan of captain
marvel and cards herself miss marvel
it's doing a great job building out
humanity it's doing a great job building
up family stories it's doing a great job
really remastering a character's power
set to work in a different medium which
you have to do sometimes and it's
introducing us to a brand new actress
this is her debut performance a lot of
american audiences including myself
don't know most of these actors on
screen and we love them we're so
invested in them internet it is future
koi as promised i just finished the miss
marvel finale and it did stick the
landing i had said i hoped it would land
somewhere in that 13 to 16 range and it
has that is a beautiful a range this to
me is before moon night and just after
iron man 3. iron man 3 begins my my god
tier this is right there in that
beautiful sweet spot it stuck the
landing it introduced lots of new plot
it gave us loving characters it gave us
so much emotion while also building out
the world while also giving us some very
interesting power sets and it gave us a
cameo from greg alba it is about 16 for
me i'd say what do you think greg
16. don't don't not not you no it's too
big top 12 or into the solid a range
these are films that would be between a
93 and a 96 if we're grading it like
american school system and my most
controversial take this is for greg
these comments
they're for you greg the seo you ready
eternals eternals is number 12. i love
this movie because it did what in my
opinion no team comic movie had been
able to do without prior team movies
none of these characters were known to
anyone except the most die-hard comic
fan it introduced 12 characters
effectively because i'm gonna count the
black knight i'm gonna count some of the
sporting casts that are so important to
this it introduced all of them and they
were so well characterized that even
when they were off screen i knew how
they would in their essence as a
character be affected by the events and
it didn't have to be redundant it didn't
have to re-spell things and it did all
that while subverting expectations by
having the villains be effectively what
we would be perceived as those humanoid
things as they evolved had sentience had
intelligence and in many ways the
eternals who we just met who we just
invested in are the villains the way
this lands is they threw off billions of
lives potential to exist while saving us
as earthlings we
were cannon fodder and yet billions of
lives were sacrificed by these hero
villains because they're both in a way
and they're above us and it established
a hierarchy of gods and it gave us so
many very very powerful visuals and
moments that grew out the mcu and it
really showed much like iron man 3 the
different type of movie an mcu film can
be this film is an art house film about
what it means to be human by way of what
it means to be an eternal and i cannot
wait to see where the ramifications of
the third act of this film go into phase
four and beyond this movie i really
think and hope with time will grow in
people's hearts because it is so special
number 11 is a movie i honestly can say
i waited most of my childhood for it was
a movie that gave me a spider-man that
sometimes did heroics for a churro it
gave me a spider-man that felt like at
least in the first 20 minutes had a
burrow to take care of and the reason
this one is as high admittedly as it is
because this one's a little tricky is
the villain vulture is one of my
rushmore marvel villains in a couple
glances michael keaton is both
intimidating and paternal you understand
he's fighting for his family you
understand how it ties into the mcu just
like mysterio i think honestly the
spider-man films as a trilogy are the
greatest tie into the mcu which is
ironic because they're a sony marvel
collaboration but they invest you in the
past while moving you forward in the
future he's a guy that's cleaning up
it's a different take on damage control
that i think they've had to remaster a
bit because they're going to do a show
but it makes you invest in the fallout
of superheroic elements that's something
that is huge in the comics is not
addressed enough in the movies those
fallouts are things that made him a
vulture he was a scavenger of tech and
he became a villain and he cared about
his daughters that invested in both
peter parker and spider-man that's the
thing about spider-man what makes
spider-man unique is you're as invested
as peter as you and as you are in
spider-man and that's what the vulture
brought and tom holland is the pitch
perfect cinematic spider-man i argue
andrew garfield is a comic book
adaptation come to life and toby mcguire
is exactly the one we needed in the
2000s the best mcu spider-man just like
ruffalo is the best mcu hulk is tom
holland and he really got to debut very
strong here the moment you met him in
civil war you wanted this movie and then
this movie delivered and it's honestly
one of the most impressive and authentic
high school casts i've seen they feel
real they feel grounded and that allows
the elevation of spider-man love this
movie number 10 we're into the top ten
these are all comfortable a bordering on
a pluses i got black panther as my
number 10. i love this movie i love what
it did to the world of marvel the people
that love this movie aren't just marvel
fans the people that celebrate this
movie are everyone from rappers i love
to grandparents and killmonger again the
theme of villains here is someone that
has a lot of just american ideals
there's a lot of just like that guy
makes sense to a lot of people and
what's beautiful is black panther learns
from killmonger killmonger says we need
to share this we need to explore
bringing this out to other people and
black panther actually ends up agreeing
with him the way this movie ends is the
hero learning from the villain
killmonger makes a lot of sense in a lot
of ways and not in the thanos was right
way in a practical sense so yes in a lot
of ways you need to keep wakanda
protected and a lot of ways you need to
share the world what your gifts are so
it's a beautiful story in a hundred ways
there's a lot of beautiful metaphors
about the underground railroad that are
used in the third act a lot of people
have some problems with the third act
and some of the cgi if the story is as
good as the story is it doesn't bother
me this movie is from its sound design
to its score to its soundtrack to its
visual effects for the most part to its
cast to its science to its world
building to its supporting cast to every
element of this film to the designs in
the embroidery in the black panther suit
this film is damn near perfect and i
think that the world of cinema is better
for it and i think that these stakes on
black panther 2 couldn't be higher
because how do you follow black panther
this movie
changed cinema and it certainly changed
the mcu if number 10 changed cinema
number nine changed television and that
you could make a superhero show that was
an existential crisis that was literally
a think piece that felt like you were
reading some of the densest philosophy
man of the dances some from very dense
philosophy
from your college professor loki dealt
with what it meant to be a human by
dealing with what it meant to be outside
of time and be a god thor is fascinating
because it's a story of humanity by way
of a god loki is arguably more
fascinating because he's someone that
wants to belong that's also a god of
mischief that feels like in some ways
he's been mislabeled how do you get your
superpowers and then kind of judge what
those imply how do you figure out who
you are as a person if you're inherently
deceitful how do you shape your reality
if you don't believe in a necessary
reality add time travel to that that is
beautifully well done add an incredible
element of government regulation that's
outside of any government because it's
about time itself in very fun
referential ways add owen wilson as
mobius giving some of the best work of
his career some of the dialogue back and
forth between tom hiddleston nolan
wilson is is amongst the best character
scene work you'll see in film or tv and
then the difference between this and for
me one division is episode six where one
division was a plus one through five i
did feel like six fell off a bit loki is
a plus one through six it ends with a
shakespearean-esque monologue from our
brand new kang jonathan majors isn't
even kang yet he's the one who remains
this shifts everything in the mcu and it
feels important and it feels huge and we
haven't even technically met kang yet
because the writing is so tight so
strong cannot wait to see where kang
goes cannot wait to see the world build
out cannot wait for more loki this show
is as close to perfect as i think a show
can get final countdown you lovelies
this is eight this point on any of these
people number one depending on my mood
this is one through eight or kind of a
number one shuffle these are tied for
first we're gonna be a pluses i know
civil war doesn't get talked about
enough anymore but if you're gonna
follow up winter soldier how do you do
that you make the first at the time
comic book double spread page come to
life the airport fight was the first
time in my life i ever felt like i did
that like double fold out and was like
they made a comic book everyone fighting
in that environment feeling exactly like
their characters doing exactly how i'd
wanted those characters see come to life
and the characterization was fascinating
you've got hero vs hero in a way that
evolves from the comics this isn't a
translation of the comics it's an
adaptation of the comics making it more
relevant to our world you understand
where iron man's coming from you've
fallen in love with that character you
understand where cap is coming from
you've fallen in love with that
character and then your heroes who are
perfectly characterized have to pick
sides every punch in this movie lands
twice because you feel the person
hitting and you feel the person getting
hit and it introduced black panther and
it introduced baron zemo and it gave us
one of the best translations of
spider-man i think we'll ever see on
screen all in one movie while you're
invested in someone who never has to
fire a bullet really baron zemo does all
of this behind doors like emperor
palpatine while still being more
charming and impossibly captivating
leading us into phase four and beyond
and giving us some of the best action
the mcu has ever had civil war a plus
number seven avengers end game this
movie delivered on an impossible promise
hey we're gonna follow up infinity war
and we're gonna tell the conclusion to
three phases of filmmaking we're gonna
conclude 12 years of cinema and we're
not going to let you down we're going to
give you the biggest action you could
conceive of we're gonna give you comic
panels come to life and the characters
that aren't their comic counterpart the
film sorry they are the comic
counterpart these are the film versions
of the characters we've lived with long
enough that they're doing different
things their comic counterparts might
because that's who they are i love that
this movie goes completely different
ways this movie is a beautiful
conclusion the infinity saga but i as a
comic book fan didn't feel like it was
color by numbers i got to experience an
entirely new story with characters i've
loved for 30 years and they did it with
style with panache and with consequence
the reason this movie is so high is
there are still consequences to this day
the infinity saga has iron man go from
selfish to selfless he sacrifices
himself at the end of end game it has
captain america go from selflesh to
selfish and i know that's in english a
bad word it's a swear but sometimes you
need to choose yourself and that's what
i mean by selfish he's finally done
fighting he's a soldier that served his
time he's going to peggy he has chosen
to choose himself and then all through
that journey you've got thor finding his
sense of self the big three are all on a
journey of self and this somehow sticks
that landing and brings 20 some odd
characters to the fold never do any of
them feel wasted and never do any of
them feel like they're just serving the
plot thanos handled beautifully we'll
talk about infinity war in a second but
endgame is a movie that shouldn't be
possible number six i don't know how
this exists this was before we were into
the mcu that deep this movie came out in
2012 we're only four years into the mcu
and they brought five different
franchises together this movie is the
avengers this movie is some of the
funniest catchiest most comic accurate
dialogue from these characters i
personally enjoy the dichotomy of doth
mother know you wear with her drapes
that thor opposite iron man so much
because he is that shakespearean
character in a lot of continuities and
that dichotomy works so well in this
movie captain america is a guy that's
doing more ragtag stuff as a helicopter
hella carrier drops out of the sky
they're all doing what they are as comic
book entities to a level that this
allowed us to evolve into them being
their movie versions of themselves this
movie brings comedy brings action brings
vibrant bright colors to this day this
is still my favorite hulk i think whole
cook's so good here and i feel like hulk
is so hulk here and you've got every
other element of the movie bringing this
all together shield feels like a real
thing all of these characters feel like
they're fully people you could somehow
meet and it's the first of its kind the
imagination and ingenuity of this cannot
be overstated a lot of people that are
in their teens now don't understand how
big a deal this was movies didn't
combine with other movies you didn't go
watch keanu reeves in one movie and he
meet john wick keon reeves in another
movie we do that in this movie it's a
bad example you don't combine franchises
this movie put different heroes from
different franchises together into one
thing that seemed impossible and they
nailed it this movie is a miracle truly
interchangeable seriously these eight
but this one at the top five are
insanely number one uh iron man started
all of this iron man was the biggest
gamble maybe in the the possibilities of
the mcu you've got an actor that wasn't
known for this kind of work you've got
john favreau who isn't yet the john
favreau that we trust to just do
whatever and they trusted him to do
whatever this is a movie that is so rock
and roll every song is ac dc this is a
movie with a character stanley invented
to be unlikable it was like a challenge
to himself he was like i'm gonna make
this guy that's aggressively selfish and
is kind of a warmonger i'm gonna turn
into a hero and they cast a guy that is
that and they turned him into a hero
like downey junior stark wouldn't work
if anyone else said those lines the
reason sam rockwell got cast in iron man
2 is because he went out for iron man 1.
tony stark is downey jr downey jr is
tony stark that is a one-of-one
experience and this movie is so
effortlessly cool everything about this
movie absolutely rocks and it was the
first so they got away especially with
jeff bridges iron monger it makes sense
for the industrial complex capitalism
all the things that turn someone into
that greed is iron monger and it
actually works better for me than in the
comics this character works opposite its
villain the movie works beat by beat the
comedy is spectacular and it gives us
the birth of the mcu and holds up 14
years later with all the advancements in
superhero stuff it's hard to make a
movie that's timeless and iron man
absolutely is okay we talked about
in-game being very hard to top infinity
wards because infinity war to me is
number four this is a movie that's
around the villain infinity war is a
thanos movie avengers brought the
avengers together and showed us you can
combine genres infinity war showed us
hey you know those people you like we're
gonna give you a villain that yes i'm
gonna say it is better than darth vader
we're gonna give you a villain you
identify with that some of you think
might be right and we're gonna make you
invest in someone that's willing to get
rid of half the population there's
moments where you're like that is a
rational thought and you're fighting the
people you've loved for so many movies
this does what avengers 1 did
exponentially it brings in infinitely
more characters it gives you some of the
greatest fight scenes in history it has
that moment where like thor lands and
you're just like overwhelmed with like
how did this even happen i love the
mjolnir cap scene in endgame but i love
even more that this movie gives you so
many of those moments and it doesn't
have to feel like a conclusion end game
needed to end everything this made you
like on the edge of your seat i remember
the credits rolled in this film and i
couldn't imagine where things could go
and for an entire year marvel had the
balls to make us wait part of my love of
this movie is the experience of that
year where i didn't know what was
possible and then somehow endgame didn't
let us down but it's because of infinity
war's launch that i think the mcu is as
strong as it is infinity war a plus i
would change not a single frame so we're
gonna get a tree we're gonna get a
raccoon that talks we're gonna get a
character named star-lord and we're
gonna convince you this isn't just a
cheap ploy to sell toys we're also gonna
get a director most of you haven't heard
of and we're going to make it a lot of
very very almost r-rated joke and we're
going to keep this all in space and
we're going to do this into phase 2 so
it doesn't actually connect to the
characters you care so much about and
we're going to make one of the best
comic book movies of all time guardians
of the galaxy one
is insane it's pure madness you care
about an entire team in one movie you
care about a team of miscreant
degenerates in one movie you are so
invested in them that when a giant tree
dies
you cry with him because we are groot
everything about this movie is
emotionally emotionally manipulative and
i say that as a compliment everything
about this movie pulls at every
heartstring you have while giving you
insane cosmic visuals i maintain without
guardians of the galaxy they weren't
gonna go cosmic i think they were gonna
let james gunn make a little side
mission with guardians and then the
movie was as good as it was and they
were like let's uh let's see if we can
steer the ship and now we have eternity
in the mcu now we're gonna have the
living tribunal and maybe secret wars
all of these things are possible because
i think of the little movie that could
one of the braver choices next to iron
man and the entire mcu and one of the
best how does this exist and it stuck
the landing guardians of the galaxy
number three this movie was number one
for seven years this was the movie i
didn't think could be dethroned this is
2015's
we're gonna make an espionage thriller
that you your dad your grandpa your
grandma your aunt your cousin your dog
walker everyone is gonna go [ __ ] yeah
winter soldier winter soldier brought
back bucky and that is a new to this
time comic book story and made me care
about bucky more than the comic ever had
it gave me a badass villain that is very
similar to its hero again a trope in
marvel that this master cap and winter
soldier are so similar they just went
off one path fell off one train in this
case and you're so invested in what this
character's journey is and you love cap
and that's without talking about the
action the elevator sequence the knife
fight on the street the stuff they're
able to do with crossbones the way this
movie is about not trusting the systems
you've trusted from the jump this is
seven years in the mcu seven years of
like shield are our people they're
protectors they're the organization that
keeps us shape we're gonna assemble a
special team we just had the avengers
defend us from cosmic threats the
shotari and now the threats are coming
from within how do you top a space demon
coming at you that's the god of
mischievous wielding them you make the
threat inside you make it the systems
that you trust
not being trustworthy and you make
captain america go wait a second in his
second [ __ ] solo movie winter
shoulder did all of the things exactly
right and gave us to this day in my
opinion the best action in the mcu love
winter soldier it's only topped by one
film it finally happened and this is an
interesting thing because i know a lot
of this is my own bias i never thought
i'd see a spider-man on screen that felt
like everything i love about spider-man
and i never thought i would be like wait
a six-movie origin story it took the
exact perfect storm of the mcu thriving
and sony rebooting spider-man to allow
something as insane as a six-movie
origin story to exist it lets spider-man
become not the spider-man of the comic
books but the spider-man of the movies
and i've always said that tom holland is
the best movie spider-man he represents
all of the things that make spider-man
work cinematically i said a little while
ago andrew garfield to me is comic book
spider-man to me tobey maguire
spider-man is foundational to get the
gateway into comic book movies to work
he's a great gateway into what the sam
raimi movies needed to do those are
foundational the samurai movies the
x-men movies and blade movies are how
any of this exists but tom holland
managed to make all of that work in this
movie by delivering one of the most
gripping performances i i swear if he
was playing a soldier or a cop or
anything that wasn't someone that wore
tight he would have been up for an oscar
here if willem dafoe wasn't wearing a
guy that wrote a glider and was just
playing like a crazy busy business
magnate he might have got an oscar nom
here the performance in this are
incredible and this is a movie that uses
the best of metamodernism it
incorporates some nostalgia yes but it
doesn't weaponize it it doesn't fan
service it it doesn't make you go that's
a reference it uses literally a
reference like the point a meme that
shouldn't work twice and both times it
serves the story and both signs it gives
you a moment of levity because how dark
the film is spider-man is a dark
character i'm sorry gwen stacy dies him
and mary jane break up half the time
because of mephisto there's lots of
people always hunting him he's always
late on rent he's always chasing a
balance of two lives he's always alone
and losing people he's lost uncle ben
he's lost aunt may spider-man's about
loss and in this he lost literally
everything and the opening of this film
is him judging his choices and him being
a little selfish by like oh doctor
strange change this change this and it's
that moment of not only spider-man being
quippy and funny not only not realizing
because he's naive which is spider-man
but by the end sacrificing everything
because he felt like it was his fault he
has to be the one that says okay i lose
everything that's spider-man with great
power comes great responsibility in this
universe we got to have that delivered
by other spider-man we got to improve on
the spider-verse story in the spider
verse one of the greatest films that's
not what i'm saying i'm saying the
spider voice story got to involve the
medium of film it got to combine the
medium of film with the medium of comics
with the multiversal impact of a shared
mcu with sony with five spider-man
villains this movie made a sinister six
effectively work and you cared about
everyone it used everything we've loved
about superhero movies to build the
perfect film it brought us 20 years of
filmmaking to one beautiful crescendo
with comic book accurate visuals with
all the easter eggs you could want but
most importantly the heart of spider-man
my number one mcu film is spider-man no
way home and it made me believe i would
have loved it as much at age eight as
i'm gonna love it at 88 and it truly is
revolutionary and it's a near-religious
experience for me there's nothing that
makes me feel the way no hail makes me
feel spiderman has meant the world to me
since i was a kid because i've always
felt like liking comics put you over
here and the irony of spider-man being
so popular and bringing you in like
people are sharing comic book love now
but it didn't used to be that way and
and because of these movies people share
that so the beautiful irony of
spider-man making a billion dollars and
bringing people together from the
pandemic i didn't even include in my
review because that's not the movie it's
just life happened to give me the gift
of bringing the world back together to
celebrate spider-man after spider-man
was the thing that made me feel like i
was part of the world and comic books
used to make me feel like i wasn't
welcome and now they make me feel the
most welcome because i get to share this
with you guys so this franchise means
the world to me spider-man means the
world to me i accept my bias i know
you're going to get uppity i know you're
going to be like that movie just came
out no way home's overrated and they use
nostalgia i don't give a [ __ ] it
affected me to a level that i can't
describe and i only hope that you ever
dear audience feel the way i feel about
that movie about anything in your life
so uh thank you for watching this whole
i assume very long video thank you for
giving a single about my opinion of
movies i've invested my life into the
comic books that inspired these movies
and these movies have given me almost 15
years of joy happiness and belief that
these dreams can come true so this video
is a culmination of all of that and this
video is me sharing with you my own
personal opinions i would honestly love
to hear yours please leave a comment i'm
going to read them up until they get
angry i'm going to read them up until
they get toxic it's inevitable because
opinions are personal this was personal
to me thank you to reject nation for
being so supportive
i hope you continue to be
enjoy this list let me know you think in
the comments below like subscribe hit
that bell we're gonna be doing lots more
videos if you guys like this list and
you watch this whole [ __ ] thing let
me know that as well because there's a
lot more lists we can do and i love
ranking stuff and it's not about what's
best it's about your experience with art
and that's all we can up for in life is
to experience art much love
[Music]